Brasil podría renovar el liderazgo en la
lucha contra el cambio climático es lo
que esperan los especialistas luego de
la Victoria electoral de Lula un suceso
que restauró la esperanza en un aspecto
criticado durante el gobierno de Yair
bolsonaro tenemos un gobierno el
gobierno demostró ser una verdadera
bomba climática una máquina para generar
calentamiento global y arrojar carbono a
la atmósfera del planeta
abandonó y negó la agenda climática hizo
todo lo posible por destruir la gestión
Ambiental de nuestro país especialmente
en la amazonía nuestro foco más
importante
el re perfilamiento brasileño en materia
medioambiental podría haberse reflejado
en la Cumbre de la cop 27 que se
celebrará la próxima semana en Egipto el
presidente electo marcaría el cambio al
enviar representantes propios a la cita
creo que lo importante es la señal que
se dará en la cop 27 y ya no será tiempo
de chantajes creo que es hora de
predicar con el ejemplo y hacer los
deberes el gobierno de bolsonaro fue a
la Cumbre a decir que si el mundo
desarrollado no pagó para proteger la
amazonía no se podía hacer nada al
respecto es una postura que Brasil nunca
tuvo
durante su campaña Lula aseguró
modificaciones en los lineamientos de
Brasil la protección de la amazonía y la
reducción de emisión de carbono fueron
focos centrales pero también se
comprometió a tomar medidas contra la
tala ilegal la minería y la ocupación de
tierras deforestadas